hemos visto que un banco puede comprar
un montón de hipotecas lo que los
convierte en prestamistas y a esas
hipotecas las encajan en alguna entidad
con un propósito especial para después
vender esas acciones en la entidad y a
esas acciones se les llama títulos
respaldados por hipotecas ahora digamos
que cuando venden esas acciones venden
cada una el supongamos diez dólares de
dólares por acción y promete un
rendimiento del 8 por ciento 8 por
ciento en rendimiento ahora vamos con
los dueños de las casas ellos quizás
están pagando un interés más alto que el
8%
tal vez fallan los pagos y bueno al
final de todo tal vez el banco se queda
con algo de dinero hacen movimientos
necesarios y bueno todo esto al
inversionista se le da el 8 por ciento
de rendimiento esto puede ser bastante
bueno para una clase de inversionistas
les puede gustar el perfil de seguridad
el perfil de riesgo y quizás también lo
que van a recibir así que ellos se
lanzan pero pueden ver también otra
clase de inversionistas como las
pensiones que tienen aversión al riesgo
y yo dicen sabes que este respaldo de
hipotecas
es de alto riesgo así que mejor no es de
alto riesgo ellos tal vez analizaron
todo este asunto y dicen bueno espera
algunos de estos títulos son títulos de
hipotecas 'subprime' algunos se ven
medios sospechosos y bueno no les agrada
el asunto no no no les gusta así que tal
vez el banco de inversiones contrata una
agencia de calificación agencia de
calificación y así tienen más
credibilidad entonces la agencia de
calificación quizás ve esta ve a esta
entidad ya estos otros seguros y diga
bueno mira yo digo que estos seguros
deben tener una calificación supongamos
que dice w así que no son tan seguros
pero tampoco son de un alto riesgo pero
para las pensiones esto no es lo
suficientemente seguro ahora por otro
lado tal vez hay personas que les gusta
el riesgo así que tal vez tenemos aquí a
un fondo de cobertura y no todos son
claro de alto riesgo pero digamos que
aquí están estos y ellos dicen que este
8% es muy bajo este 8% es muy bajo
ahora los banqueros son personas super
creativas ellos dicen bueno mira aquí
tenemos estas personas que quieren
comprar seguros pero dicen que este es
muy riesgoso para sus gustos y hay otros
inversionistas que pueden comprar
seguros que pueden tomar más riesgo pero
dicen que el 8% es muy bajo así que yo
en lugar de perder con estos
inversionistas porque no simplemente
divido a esta entidad la divido en dos
tramos así que los banqueros hacen eso
lo dividen dividen la entidad
primeramente por aquí los tramos de
hechos son son tres no son dos el primer
tramo es el tramo preferente el tramo
preferente en segundo es el tramo de
entrepiso tramo de entrepiso y el
tercero es el tramo de equidad el tramo
de equidad oye pero chicas del vídeo
cómo funciona a bueno deja te digo en
esta situación cuando tenemos tramos lo
que hacemos es al tramo preferente se le
paga primero cuando éste esté completo
ahora sigue el de entrepiso se le paga
el cuando éste esté completo después se
le pagará al de equidad al tramo de
equidad ahora
si nadie de aquí se le llama obligación
de deudas garantizadas obligación de
deudas garantizadas que se abrevia o
deje o deje y es un derivado del seguro
de hipotecas aquí lo que hicimos fue
acomodar todo de otra manera y te
preguntarás bueno esto como resuelve el
problema bueno pues ahora la agencia de
calificación dirá mira al tramo
preferente se le pagará primero entonces
a ellos le daremos mayor calificación de
hecho el tramo preferente ahora puede
obtener un seguro y también una permuta
de incumplimiento crediticio lo pueden
calificar triple 'a' y ahora estas
pensiones pueden comprar estos o dejes
del tramo preferente y tal vez paguen
menos interés quizás el 5% ahora los de
entrepiso ellos siguen en el pago así
que tal vez mantengan una calificación
doble ven y reciban el 8 por ciento
digamos y luego el tramo de equidad
ellos recibirán un mayor interés digamos
que del 15 por ciento a cambio de haber
sido los últimos en el pago y bueno en
fin ya con todos estos arreglos todo
mundo está contento todo el mundo feliz
porque las pensiones están aseguradas
hay menos rendimiento los fondos de
cobertura se vuelven un poco más
pero tienen mayor rendimiento así que
todo el mundo está contento